[Music]
trade offer for felix
we receive a meme review with rick
astley you receive
no more rick rolls let me consider this
option
no you can't rick roll me it's
impossible
i'll prove it there will be no rick ross
this entire episode
one strike the video ends when you
realize pewdiepie has been posing
youtube videos for 10 years but hasn't
made a single pie review
how about y'all honestly i don't even
like pie i don't tell you guys
my whole life is a lie okay i'm not even
feeling kajal burger i'm bing bong
huh one year since pewd's yo-yo video
one year since i bought my first yo-yo
no way that's sick yeah
this could have been me if i kept
practicing
but i didn't i did nothing but play
video games
look at that i could have had a life
skill
whoa sick
that's awesome i challenge you to show
your progress
oh sorry my fingers i broke all of them
at the same time i'm so
i wish i could help marcy i met a
homeless person and was kind enough to
take a selfie with her
well at least it's not a rickroll you
know what i'll take it pewds sees my
meme pewtsy is my other meme pewds is my
petition he likes it and now
i saw it coming i was you saw i was
ready to pause it doesn't count
that was so obvious why would this be a
video
that's extremely sus doesn't count get
out of here
ski that'll be minecraft sears one
minecraft series 2
the industrial revolution of minecraft
we will destroy this earth
we will harvest it for its minerals and
materials and
just kill it i don't know i feel like
killing it
hey felix can you tell ken i like this
shirt sure i'll tell him
i like it too thanks my kids picked it
up he already replied
oh great what the [ __ ] is this
yuck you're using light mode now i dare
to click
ah again you're using that one
still in the game get a little game huge
pp
well done of course dark mode of course
always of course my eyes are so
sensitive i see
i see and light that's what happens when
i hit the light mode
also it's so bright for my precious
little eyes i can't look at this
my merchandise what happened to me oh
where's the dark mode i'm a gamer i
spend at least 12 hours a day on
computer you cannot use live mode you're
[ __ ] idiots
do you want to see the most illegal
thing i own coco
delete that folder now delete it now
delete that folder now or there will be
consequences
what do you say felix do we have a deal
i receive big pp
you receive a like on your youtube video
of course
of course a great offer i accept
shake on it
[Applause]
iron arm is easier to get than leather
armor yeah why is that mojang
why is that explain yourself you fools
your imbeciles you don't even know your
own game
and why can't i make two stairs into one
block
explain yourself mojang
this could be a rickroll yep
there it is i [ __ ] near [ __ ] i hope
you're burning agony
pain suffering a thousand years in
prison of
doom i hope cthulhu sucks out your soul
and rick ashley
poops on your sorry that was a bit too
much pewter a photo appeared
as a drone which i edited and got 50 000
uploads
skips one day of the wine misses it me
hey sorry i missed some memes type it
into that yeah
side take the blade side take the plane
all right what are you gonna do contact
hr
get out of here sorry i'm kidding uh i
turned pewdiepie into caption america
and captain swedish i'm so confused it's
sick though
i like it a lot huge pp ginormous
one might even say all right here we go
you give one sub
i received one sub think about it you
don't have to make up your mind right
now and if it's a no
feel free to well i'll always be here
come back anytime
this is my sales pace think it's working
this is what you want to do when someone
talks to you and you don't care
i'll be the best salesman you know it
girls buy all the sh
thank you girls meanwhile boys
i'm sorry boys i will have to cut off
you know what i must do girls buy more
merch okay
i will not push this joke further for
afraid of cancellation
but maybe i will okay all right nick
fury and maze window on meme review
yes just like that it's been done
thank you what the [ __ ] is this this is
real
it's amazing photograph me giving an
award to a post after claiming my free
reward from reddit
miss star beast i am e star beast
we can hone this team what is this math
teacher today we are going to practice
multiples of 64.
that kid that plays minecraft 128
32 16. oh [ __ ] i knew them all
you don't need math you just need
minecraft
i died after two years two years i died
after a few months months i died after a
few weeks
y'all getting to live you guys are dying
get it download tuber simulator today i
will get a download
you will get a good time
think about it yo
back in the year hundred they said
that's probably the year
they still did this oh and that wheels
on that bad boy too
damn damn
sick chair bro this is actually a
prototype right here
feels getting new sven meanwhile
original sven it's dark sven
get it right nerds evil spin
[Laughter]
yo no rickrolls by the way killing the
game
[Laughter]
cute aside put whatever you want here
sorry
i will give you i will grant you this
freedom but just know
that one thing you may not put this is
not a threat
[Music]
all right that camera's gonna fall okay
you can't run from me uh the speed's not
about this
yes it's real influence
[Music]
who the [ __ ] is gameplay get out of here
stella skidaddle stella
no one wants you here what is this is
this angry birds excuse me
what the [ __ ] is angry birds up to i'm
so confused
what is happening here what's the story
whatever your son
my son
[Laughter]
some random guy if we all sub to pits
twice
he would have 200 million subs the 50
million of us that already did
that [ __ ]
[ __ ] come on do something come on
guys subscribe my sub cam will go up
think about it how do you feel about
that
68 following you know what you must do
all right who should be my number 69
peter griffin
done it is done my young ep
younglings okay for years we have asked
for
the yearly flip challenge now we ask
again
where is bottle flip challenge 2021 has
it already been a [ __ ] year
god damn it i don't like that i haven't
practiced at all this year i gotta be
honest with you guys
who missed me we've been tricked we've
been backstabbed
and we've been quite possibly bamboozled
no
no no ks
i no how could you do this
get off the site bro here is some
footage showing the difference between
4k and 8k
me watching in 480p interesting
i could tell the difference on the
pixels over here
i prefer the real checker oh yeah all
right come on these are a bit tired
don't you think how do you feel about
that
i criticize your meme in front of
millions of viewers
hurts doesn't it that's okay not
everything has to be pleasant
now subscribe and you'll feel better
officially 19 years old and dreaming of
excitement that's a sick piece
but that's a cake
i speak english that's a cake happy
birthday
oh [ __ ] hate cats but i'm a cat all
along i never even thought about that
sheesh do i feel stupid about that how
do i feel about that
not very good i feel dumb everyone
always calls me out on everything that i
say that contradicts itself which
inevitably is everything at this point
so stop reminding me
okay [ __ ] it no more cat ears is this
what you want
he's about to say his first word giga
automatic self
shorting self automatic self evident
system
okay rick roll no no
so basically he will work for me and i
will sell him his own crops
some capitalism kid listen
i offer it will work for me tirelessly
endlessly
24 hours and uh you will pay me
deal we got a deal shake chickaroonie
you want to think about it that's all
right i'll be right here bro take your
time
but if anything would happen to your
daughter okay sorry
why is this stuck girls buy all this
thank you girls you're welcome
what the it's like launched in there
me makes a mediocre meme piers you drop
this well the smallest penis
hey king you dropped these
what do you think you're listening to
where are you going to be baby
go go go go go
yes yes very good
no no i saw it coming from a mile away
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] off
that was some oh my mo [ __ ]
[Music]
pewdiepie or hell
kind of sick not gonna lie mojeng wen
moji pewdiepie that's all that's my
sales pitch
another video all right let's do this
okay we're safe no no we're not no we're
not [ __ ] off
stop it small pippy i will download all
of you
a possible way to get donkey out of mine
card uh-huh
yeah sure get out of here skedaddle you
[ __ ] you
set that up you snake you
fall vermin rat demon stop it
i'm too smart for you guys just admit it
who wore it better
daddy that's some
bad energy right there at this point
rick rolling pits is getting cringy
because he
a [ __ ] gif it was a gif well guys
thank you for watching this episode of
the vibe subscribe
how do you feel birthday and brofist
don't ever get rickroll me again you
hear me